the 2015 Ford Mustang GT convertible is
very proud of itself it has every reason
to be the 50th anniversary model of the
iconic pony car has a 5.0 liter v8
engine that gets 435 horsepower and hits
60 miles per hour in 4.7 seconds it has
a noble muscular profile with that
unmistakable long and strong nose the
18-inch wheels look hot too like they
can take on any old Dodge or Chevy or
revving enticingly in the other way plus
it's a convertible what's not to like
well a few things let's start with the
interior a space defined by the most
uncomfortable car seats I've ever
experienced the headrests hit the middle
of my neck and there was no lumbar
support to be found the seats feel
chintzy and the covering on the steering
wheels feels cheap the shifter on the
six-speed automatic transmission feels
flimsy to use as well and it all too
easily swoops past years it's not worth
the 1,200 dollars extra you'll have to
pay for it I also take issue with the
diminutive size of the Mustang side
mirrors they're way too small
the rear visibility in here could do
with some major improvement of course
the visibility improves exponentially
the moment you take down this black
ragtop this car is meant to be driven
and shown as a convertible once the roof
is down the automatic headlamps fog
lamps dual exhausts and sporty spoiler
really pop
punch the gas and the Mustang g/t will
lunge forward with the passion of a
buckin bronc it's a great feeling I just
wish the price tag felt as good the
$42,000 base MSRP seems a little steep
for what is certainly not as
well-appointed as other vehicles in this
price range when the Mustang first came
out in 1964 it was financially
accessible even to people on a
Secretary's budget which directly
influence its rabid popularity that was
kind of the whole idea this one while
admittedly sexy on the outside and more
than capable on the road doesn't have
quite the same spirit